[Musique]
non
bonjour à tous ici alexis ii lancèrent
très très très heureux de vous retrouver
pour cette discussion en direct sur fond
de campagne électorale notre dernière
discussion en direct de las de cette
campagne on n'est qu'au jour 34 le vote
approche à grands pas au terme de cette
campagne atypique à bien des égards vous
le savez pour toutes sortes de raisons
avant de commencer je vous rappelle que
cette période de qu'on passe ensemble
elle vous est consacré en grande partie
à et vous en êtes des artisans dans la
mesure où on attend vos questions on
attend vos propositions si on veut de
discussion qu'on va voir avec nos
invités la parole est donc à vous et
n'hésitez pas à le faire une bonne demi
heure ensemble on a de quoi meubler
cette demi heure là sans aucun doute
avant de commencer je rappelle aussi
quelques détails concernant la soirée
électorale que tous les artisans
d'information à radio canada sont en
train de préparer en ce moment j'en ai
croisé quelques-uns soirée électorale
sur toutes nos plateformes lundi
prochain dès
17h55 sur ici r d radio canada.ca sur
facebook et sur youtube partout où
radio-canada information est présent 19h
sur i see première 19h30 sur ici télé et
tou.tv bref ça va être dur à manquer et
le moment est venu de souhaiter la
bienvenue à nos panélistes à mes
collaborateurs du jour à mes chers
collègues et analystes daniel thibault
qu'on retrouve à ottawa salut daniel
challe et bien et qui dans ses studios
des coulisses du pouvoir daniel
animateurs des coulisses du pouvoir et
un analyste sur bien sûr plusieurs de
nos plateformes observateurs aguerris la
scène politique fédérale tout comme aden
blême raincy chef de bureau
parlementaire toujours un plaisir de
retrouver madeleine merci bonjour tout
le monde alors avant de commencer bien
entendu il faut garder en tête qu'il ya
un côté bilan à notre discussion c'est
un c'est pas tout à fait fini c'est le
vrai véritablement le sprint final qui
s'amorce en ce moment tout le monde est
dans le sud de l'ontario ça nous indique
ou presque lors ça nous indique à quel
point les endroits où ça peut se jouer
mais j'aimerais vous entendre tour à
tour vos réflexions instinctive sur
cette campagne qui gens comme moi m'a
surpris à certains égards est ce que
vous attendiez madeleine à ce type de
campagne et à la tournure que ça a pris
non pas vraiment parce qu'au début de la
campagne électorale on se demandait si
justin trudeau obtiendrait oui ou non
une majorité et après quelques jours on
s'est dit au plat et justin trudeau est
en train de se battre pour conserver le
pouvoir donc l'hypothèse de départ la
question de départ avait complètement
changé et à mon avis alexis
commentateurs qui dans une prochaine
élection dirait 24 heures 48 heures
après le déclenchement d'une élection on
n'en parle plus du déclenchement je
pense que il y penserait avant de
prononcer cette phrase là parce qu'elle
ne s'est pas avérée 7 cette vérité là
qu'ont dénoncée comme une vérité dans le
fait qu'on on parle plus du
déclenchement des élections de après
quelques jours cette fois ci ça a était
l'exception qui a confirmé la règle on
en a parlé pendant des jours de cette
décision de justice qui veut déclencher
des élections en pleine pandémie et un
o'toole a surpris un peu pour les
libéraux du moins parce qu'il a grimpé
dans les sondages au début de la
campagne puis après bon la course a été
plus difficile pour lui et on est
presque à la ligne d'arrivée quand on se
demande un peu qu'ils veulent emporter
ce qui rend la soirée électorale très
well soirée qui risque d'être longue
avec en plus le vote par correspondance
qui est assez volumineux on compte tous
à partir du lendemain à la mitaine waouh
il va avoir des luttes serrées on y
revient dans quelques instants les
questions sont nombreuses on complète ce
tour de table daniel sur les impressions
à ce stade-ci de la campagne par rapport
ce qu on entrevoyait au tout départ
j'aimerais vous entendre dessus ouais ça
va du côté des libéraux que ce serait ça
se ferait à l'arraché que ce serait pas
une victoire simple si elle victoire que
ce serait chirurgicale qu'on ira
chercher des sièges des petites des
petits blocs de siège un peu partout à
travers le pays c'est comme ça qu'on
l'avait imaginé la campagne à 18 heures
ce que l'on appelle dans le jargon le
procès historique
cette capacité pour un parti de dieu est
bon voici ont déclenché élections non
pas pendant 36 48 heures après ça s'est
terminé c'est vrai que libéraux étaient
convaincus que ça allait pas assez sain
et c'est comme si on n'avait pas pensé
une justification adéquate du côté du du
camp libéral avant de déclencher c'est
ce qui fait que ça traînait dans
d'abandon dans la sphère publique
pendant plusieurs plusieurs jours
plusieurs semaines à certains égards
c'est encore soulever aujourd'hui
parler par les conservateurs et les
néo-démocrates
on a eu l'air d'être pris de court dans
le cadre d'une élection qu'on avait
qu'ils avaient eux-même déclenchée du
côté libéral surprise aussi
effectivement
je reviendrai pas sur ce que disait ma
demande mais dans le cas dans le camp
conservateur on a eu l'impression que on
avait réussi à mieux faire - qu'est-ce
qu'ils avaient anticipé pour faire
découvrir le chef pour peut-être les
faire déguerpir il a évidemment on vient
la case départ je vous ferai pas de
surprise si je vous dis que cette fin de
semaine au coude et son bas entre autres
parlé du gouvernement qui risque d'être
de nouveau minoritaires scénario tout le
monde envisagent ou à peu près et donc
ça va soulever la question pourquoi
exactement on a tenu cet exercice nation
vient exactement avec ce que l'on avait
comme parlement avant de commencer il y
en a qui vont la soulever cette question
là ça va être intéressant de voir ce
qu'il ya ce qu'on va craindre maman
comme en réponse nous est ce que ça va
donner comme résultat au terme du
processus mais avant ça il va voir des
lieux de tresserre est question qui nous
est posée par matteo merci matteo pour
cette question très simple mais on est
vraiment au coeur des enjeux importants
stati à quel endroit risque d'y avoir
des courses très très très serré
madeleine sajoo cette élection
qu'en disait daniels et chirurgicales ça
joue à plusieurs endroits et pas
nécessairement dans un gros bloc c'est
pas par exemple uniquement dans la
banlieue de toronto qu'on dit tellement
crucial les libéraux qui voulaient
obtenir une majorité même s'il ne le
disait pas espérer faire des gains par
exemple
beauport limoilou ça c'est un siège qui
est détenu par le bloc québécois
c'est dans la grande région de québec
les libéraux pensait peut-être pouvoir
l'emporter entre autres parce que
c'était extrêmement serré la dernière
fois même chose pour trois rivières
encore une fois vous voyez c'est une
lutte qui joué entre autres avec le bloc
qui détenait le siège mais là en france
m le parti conservateur donc là on va
parler d'une lutte à trois très très
très serré ces deux exemples donc pas
nécessairement des circonscriptions qui
sont collées l'une sur l'autre je pense
à la gaspésie la gaspésie ce sont les
libéraux qui la détiennent alors que les
blocs et s'ils veulent l'arraché donc
c'est pas toujours la lutte pas toujours
dans le même sens parfois les libéraux
essaie d'arracher des sièges parfois
c'est le bloc québécois l'on parle du
québec ailleurs au pays va y avoir des
cours série quand même dans la grande
région de toronto et des courses qu'on
veut surveiller en colombie-britannique
parce que le lieu dynamique à trois qui
se perd
extrêmement difficile de prévoir ce qui
va ce qui va se passer en colombie
britannique
alors raison de plus pour penser qu'on
va se coucher très tard lundi soir parce
que le npd est fort les libéraux s'en
tire bien et le parti conservateur est
très concurrentiel donc ça fait des
dynamiques sont très très difficile de
prévoir daniel
canton juste avant le déclenchement
d'élections j'ai eu l'occasion me soir
avec un stratège libéral on a fait on a
fait le tour de toutes les provinces du
pays les 338 circonscription ça se
faisait par blocs de deux ou trois
sièges on va en gagner ici on va perdre
là au québec on va peut-être aller en
chercher trois ou quatre ce calcul l'aï
lacets site tenir je vous dirai à
mi-chemin de la campagne est là
aujourd'hui on regarde un peu où est-ce
qu'on peut sauver l'immeuble père me
permettez moi l'expression ce que vous
devriez surveiller le soir lundi soir
matteo je pense qu'avec l'antique les
choses risquent d'être assez neutre du
côté du québec les libéraux semblent
faire bonne figure toute chose étant
relative regarder les courses en ontario
la dernière fois en 2019 c'était un lac
le parti libéral avait fait le plein de
sièges à la toute dernière minute si
c'était ça qui leur avait donné le
gouvernement minoritaire est ce qu'on va
être capable de maintenir ses acquis
leur quelqu'un disait cette semaine on a
déjà on est allé chercher tout ce qu'on
pouvait aller chercher à l'ontario à
endiguer de ce côté là c'est un peu plus
compliqué puis conservateurs sont
compétitifs il ya des petites mais le
petit peut être qu'ils se sont ouvertes
pensez à l'alberta il refuse avant
quelques courses intéressantes là bas et
les libéraux pourraient aller rafler un
ou deux sièges aux conservateurs la
dynamique entre les libéraux fédéraux
monsieur kenny depuis 48 heures change
la donne de ce côté là puis évidemment
on le dit à chaque élection mais j'ai
l'impression que cette fois ci c'est
plus vrai que jamais ça va se passer
comme britannique on va attendre de voir
comment ça se déroule là-bas parce que
les courses à 3 c'est très très serré et
on parlait du vote par correspondance
les sept des dix circonscriptions où on
a demandé le plus de bulletins de vote
par correspondance
elles sont en colombie-britannique cabon
alors s'il faut qu'on attende le
résultat de course serrée où il ya dans
certains cas plusieurs milliers de
bulletins de vote par correspondance qui
ont été envoyés dans certaines
circonscriptions clés ça peut vouloir
dire qu'on va les attendre encore
quelques jours ces résultats laissent ça
va rendre la dynamique se montre la
course intéressante lundi soir dans vos
réponses vous avez madani daniel un peu
préparé le terrain pour répondre aux
autres questions que j'ai ici à vous
soumettre
à lancer avec la première ici que j'ai
sous les yeux vous partiez de ces lutte
à trois c'était à prévoir dans le
contexte où on est en ce moment mais
quand même c'est assez particulier et je
rajoute ici si on jette un coup d'oeil
aux travaux aux analyses plutôt de
philippe jugie fournier dans son système
d'agrégation de moyen de sondages en est
à 32 % deal pour les bureaux 31,7 pour
les conservateurs c'est dans ce contexte
là que justin trudeau cette semaine a
sorti la carte du vote stratégique
question ici question ici de roanne
prénommé juan merci beaucoup pour votre
question alors qui va comme suit depuis
une semaine on l'entend justin trudeau
parler de votre stratégie qu est ce que
ça fonctionne vraiment cette tactique
nous demande one madeleine si les
libéraux sorte la carte chaque fois
c'est parce qu'il pense que ça
fonctionne c'est il ya une libérale qui
me disait on va pas changer une recette
qui fonctionne et c'est toujours le même
prétexte c'est de dire on veut essayer
de bloquer la route aux conservateurs
donc on essaie chez les libéraux de
grappiller siège chez les néo-démocrates
sachant que ce sont des votes dits
progressistes donc donc c'est une
stratégie qui a été utilisée la de
mémoire ça fait une quinzaine d'années
que je trouve la politique fédérale ça a
été utilisée chaque élection peut-être
avec l'exception de 2011 la société
l'exception de la vague orange les
libéraux s'ils avaient utilisé cette
carte là ce moment là pour peut-être que
ça aurait eu un effet contraire le
peut-être qu'ils auraient poussé des
votes libéraux vers le npd mais
généralement ça s'utilise ayant une et
aux démocrates un ancien stratège en
fait mais où démocrate carl bélanger qui
me disait cette semaine à son ami plus
cette stratégie là est utilisé tôt dans
la campagne plus ça démontre le niveau
de nervosité chez les libéraux donc la
ceni ben suscite c'est relativement
normal je dirais à quelques jours du
vote ont entendu justin trudeau évoqué
cet appel ou votre progressiste depuis
quelques jours déjà donc on est dans la
dans l'ordre des choses il n'y a rien de
surprenant c'est comme ça que ça se
passe mais je voyais des conservateurs
faire un peu la même chose aujourd'hui
ou des d un journal de tendance
conservatrice le sonn disant si vous
voyez pour maxime dernier vous allez
peut-être vous retrouvez avec justin
trudeau au pouvoir disant que si le vote
du parti conservateur à la droite
s'érode au profit de maxime bernier mais
peut-être que ça va avantager parti
conservateur donc moins ça joue des deux
côtés du spectre ce vote stratégique moi
je trouve ça très intéressant cet aspect
là des choses et bien ayant un vécu et
travaillé en alberta pendant un certain
temps et là je vois que les walis troupe
de maxime bernier du parti populaire
conservateur sur les réseaux sociaux
décrypteurs c'est ce qu'on a dénoté
depuis début de la campagne ceux qui
sont dans les trending trending topics
ce du jour dans tout et tout le plus
souvent depuis le début de cette
campagne c'est ce parti cette
organisation quelle stratégie web assez
particulière parle de vague mauvais
évidemment on est loin du compte à ce
statut c'est ce qu'on peut dire mais
daniel poursuivants et termine en
concluant sur la question à votre
stratégique
et puis il ya pour que ça fonctionne
c'est vrai que ça fonctionne pour les
libéraux ça fonctionnait pas il
utiliserait pas le sondeur qui faisait
la semaine dernière il ya environ le
tiers des électeurs néo-démocrates qui
sont des progressiste qui sont disposés
à changer car s'ils ont l'impression que
leur vote peut faire un différend une
différence donc il ya 33 % de
l'électorat néo-démocrates qui est ce
type d'écouter le message des libéraux
et dira devant le risque de voir arriver
au pouvoir un gouvernement conservateur
je vais aller camper mon vote du côté
rouge pour que ça fonctionne évidemment
pour que l'appel soit fait pour que
soient crédibles et pour qu'il soit
crédible il faut qu'il y ait une menace
est là on est dans une espèce de tempête
parfaite parce que il ya effectivement
on le voit dans les sondages une
possibilité bien réelle tu es une
minorité une majorité d'un côté comme de
l'eau donc cette carte là pour le
gouvernement pour le parti de monsieur
trudeau est lé jouable et elle pourrait
être efficace
par ailleurs ce serait intéressant de
voir les troupes de maxime bernier vous
en parliez tout à l'heure
un stratège conservateur qui faisait
hier on pense qu'à peu près 75 % des
gens qui sont allés se ranger chez
maxime bernier qui viennent de chine
soit un problème est ce que ces gens là
seraient allés voter est ce que ces gens
là vont aller voter mais dans certaines
dans certaines régions l'alberta le sud
ouest ontarien d'un risque réel que ça
fasse une différence au clic des
légendes monsieur bernier que les
candidats du parti populaire du canada
allait chercher un siège parce que ça
s'est relativement
certainement peu probable mais qui
divise suffisamment le vote comme le
disait madeleine pour effectivement
permettre à un candidat libéral
ça va être intéressant de surveiller
cette dynamique là parce que on n'est
pas assez dans les deux chiffres dans
certains endroits les sondages et genou
pour le parti populaire sa nouvelle ça
donne du 10 11 % c'est anecdotique ce
sont de petits échantillonnage mais
quand même ça pourrait faire une
différence même
chose que j'entends et que je vois
souvent depuis un certain nombre de
jours et je présume que c'est alimentée
par ce qui s'est passé aux etats-unis
plusieurs prêts personnes malgré les
propos rassurants d'élections canada
s'inquiète face justement à la montée du
vote par correspondance et à l'impact
que cela peut avoir sur le processus
électoral et tout le reste questions de
vincent qui fait écho à cette
préoccupation qui je crois est quand
même assez présente dans l'esprit
certaines personnes on apprend l'art
probablement écrit-il
le résultat n'aura probablement pas le
résultat du vote le soir des élections
en raison du vote postal comme ce fut le
cas aux etats-unis 10 25 risque-t-on de
voir ici aussi des partis ou des acteurs
politiques tentés de remettre en doute
le processus électoral ou démocratique
les chefs conclut-il se sont-ils engagé
à reconnaître le résultat du vote mais
je crois que pour les principaux chefs
ça va de soi mais j'aimerais vous
entendre là dessus sur ses doutes que ça
peut entretenir dans l'esprit de
certains électeurs madeleine
moi j'ai l'impression que la remise en
question qu'on a vu aux états unis ne se
transpose transposera pas ici au canada
parce que aux états unis on avait dans
le train le chef d'un parti de chypre et
le président sortant qui contestaient
bâtiment lui-même le résultat électoral
on ne voit pas ça ici on ne voit pas est
un hôte où il commençait à dire que bon
il va douter du résultat électoral on
est loin loin loin loin loin de ce
scénario là alors je pense pas que ce
soit ça fasse partie le des grandes
préoccupations de l'électorat ici on a
vu donc cette montée du parti populaire
est ce que dans ce mouvement là qui est
plus à droite il pourrait y avoir une
remise en question du système peut-être
parce qu'il ya des partisans là dedans
qui sont un peu anti système on s'entend
mais une forme bon si on évalue dans les
sondages environ 6% selon la moyenne des
sondages qu'ont pu recueillir jusqu'à
maintenant c'est une force qui existe
mais qui est quand même pas majeur dans
le spectre politique canadien oui et la
meilleure façon finalement de rassurer
les gens c'est d'expliquer comment ça
marche comment ça fonctionne on rappelle
les pots de machines comme aux états
unis c'est à la main que ça se fait et
ça se fait qu'est-ce qu'on peut rire
comment on pourrait résumer la façon de
procéder daniel en ce qui concerne c'est
le dépouillement des votes bon eh bien
peut-être et j'ajouterais ce que disait
madeleine d'être un élément qui est
particulier aux états unis au delà de
l'appel de monsieur tron qui était non
négligeable quand même il y avait aussi
le fait que le système est géré au
niveau au niveau des états donc il y
avait de petites différences ici et là
qui ouvrait des brèches qui permettait
peut-être d'imaginer des contestations
de soulever certains problèmes ici au
canada le système de il est géré par
élections canada s'est fait au niveau
national alors le bulletin que vous avez
commandé le soleil ou con ou québec où
un nouveau brunswick ce même bulletin
vous arrive de la même façon quand il
revient chez élections canada ce but est
là il est envoyé dans la circonscription
bull enregistrés alors il sera contée
dans cette circonscription là je parle
d'expérience parce que moi je les
commande et mon petit bulletin de vote
par la poste veut les voir comment ça
fonctionnait j'étais curieux un peu voir
quel genre de système relativement
efficace je voudrais après j'ai reçu le
bulletin la maison quarante huit heures
après l'avoir commandé on leur a remis
une série d'hommes voilà rempli on mêle
bulletins dans une petite enveloppe aux
mails enveloppe dans une seconde
enveloppe la seconde enveloppe elle est
adressée à la circonscription elle et
elle redirige le bulletin dans la
circonscription où les lecteurs et donc
au fur et à mesure où les bulletins
arrivent ils sont renvoyés dans la
circonscription et après la fermeture
des bureaux de scrutin on va compter les
votes dans les boîtes et ensuite on va
se mettre à compter ce qui a été reçu
par correspondance ajoutez à cela le
fait qu'on cesse d'accepter les votes
par correspondance au moment de la
fermeture des bureaux de scrutin lundi
soir donc il ya des votes via des
bulletins de vote qui vont présumément
arriver un peu plus tard dans le courant
de la semaine on prendra les comptes est
aussi cela élections canada cette
semaine normalement sur une heure
ceux qui sont plus tard il ne les compte
pas si je prends après non ce qui arrive
ce qui arrive après l'heure limite ne
seront pas comptés mais ce qui arrive au
moment le jour-même n'arriveront pas
immédiatement dans un bureau de vote ils
vont devoir être acheminés aux bureaux
de vote et comptait ensuite on nous
disait que le
retour normalement le taux de retour
quand on a des votes par correspondance
à l'étranger c'est d'environ 75%
jusqu'ici on pense que le taux de retour
fluctue dans les environs de 50 % on se
demande à quel point ça va monter
davantage et pas d'indications elle
effectue un niveau d'impopularité
certain nombre de vérifications
de vote par correspondance pour
s'assurer que la personne n'a pas nos
aussi voter en personne à ce moment là
c'est la raison pour laquelle ça se fait
au niveau de la circonscription et c'est
la raison pour laquelle la soirée
électorale risque d'être longue et voire
même se prolongèrent que le résultat
définitif parce qu'à ce stade-ci faut
pas l'attendre le lundi soir là de façon
claire est certaine c'est sûr elle s'il
est en fils usher amis et j'aurais tant
aimé poursuivre cette discussion encore
pendant plusieurs minutes il en reste
cinq à peu près en ce moment une
question de sophie qui je crois est très
pertinente puisque c'est vraiment ça a
marqué la campagne du début à la fin
voici la question de se fier où la
parole est ensuite donnée les madeleines
quel effet va finalement avoir eu la
pandémie de gober 19 sur la campagne
madeleine
c'est particulier parce qu'on peut pas
le mesurer encore parce qu'il vient de
se passer dans la campagne électorale
quelque chose qui aura mené la gestion
de la pandémie vraiment à l'avant plan
et c'est la volte face de jason kenny en
alberta qui vient embêter par
association et renault tour donc à la
toute fin de la campagne juste avant que
les gens recommencent d'accord à aller
voter d'une certaine façon il y arrive
cet événement qui quand même assez de
marquant dans la campagne jason kenny
avait appuyé un o'toole dans la course à
la direction du parti un peu plus d'un
an à l'époque ça avait donné un élan
aéronautes houle là cette semaine sa
présence représenté pratiquement plus un
boulet pour le chef conservateur
pour deux raisons hérin o'toole inventé
dans le passé la gestion de la pandémie
de jason kenny premièrement et
deuxièmement il pourrait encore une fois
être en embêter sur sa droite encore une
fois par le parti de maxime bernier
c'est comme si c'est difficile pour un
o'toole de gagner dans cette situation
là non seulement on peut certains
électeurs peuvent penser à 6 et 1
conservateurs qui gouvernent
est-ce qu'il va avoir des politiques qui
seront pas suffisamment
rigoureuse ou forte pour contrôler
l'académie d'une part et dont on se dit
si c'est un conservateur qui fait volte
face qui ramène le passeport vaccinale
on a envie associe donc maxime bernier
essayer de capitaliser là dessus donc
vous voyez c'est compliqué pour rire à
nantes où sa stratégie à lui c'est de
pivoter critique et justin trudeau pour
avoir déclenché des élections en pleine
pandémie peut-être que justin trudeau va
porter une partie du blâme chez certains
électeurs pour cette décision d'avoir
déclenché des élections cet été mais je
dirais quand même le kop en bout de
ligne si on fait si on fait les
équilibres dans tout ça peut-être qu'une
ampoule va avoir
eu une journée plus difficile et donc
que ça va avoir marqué la fin de la
campagne daniel
le jour du vote la façon dont la
pandémie marquera le jour du vote c'est
difficile de déterminer pour l'instant
je pense que l'élection canada a préparé
le terrain pour sa chérie tu aurais pas
de 2,2 de problème similaire à ce que
l'on a vu par exemple à
terre-neuve-et-labrador l'hiver dernier
ce qui est intéressant c'est que les
parties je ne veux pas que la pandémie a
eu sur la fin la campagne s'était posé
la question dans tous les cas à peu près
sur ce que ça pourrait vouloir dire il y
avait des scénarios est ce qu'on
pourrait devoir mettre un terme à la
tournée nationale à un moment donné il
faudra limiter la campagne à certains
d'en cas les conservatoires on avait
même préparé un studio ici dans la
région d'ottawa
force est de constater que ça s'est
relativement bien passé dans l'ensemble
maintenant ce que ça voudra dire la
semaine prochaine en termes de livraison
le jour pour la sortie du vote ça ça
risque de compliquer les choses d'une
province à l'autre ce serait intéressant
de voir si en alberta saskatchewan les
mesures sanitaires ont été resserrées au
cours des derniers jours est ce que ça
pourrait avoir un impact et puis bon je
reviendrai pas sur ce que madeleine 10
est effectivement en termes d'un point
de vue strictement politique c'est un
impact sur la campagne des conservateurs
très incertaine ouais un enjeu wedge
tout un enjeu de brèches qui a tenté
d'être mis de l'avant par certains
acteurs politiques
on verra si ça sera a été ou non à leur
avantage je rappelle à tout le monde
qu'ils nous écoutent un là le jour du
choix final arrive pour bon nombre
d'entre vous n'hésitez pas vous tourner
sur nos plateformes on a fait des
vérifications de fait tout au long de la
campagne on a un comparateur de
programmes ou de plateformes politiques
il ya aussi des analyses de nos
collègues qui sont disponibles sur
toutes nos plateformes que vous allez
relire pour vous faire une tête avant de
faire de faire votre choix dans l'urne
madeleine et daniel jault merci
infiniment de votre participation à ce à
sa discussion en direct on va vous
écoutez d'ici à la soirée électorale et
lors de la soirée électorale voulue bien
à seront essentiels comme toujours merci
chers collègues au revoir plaisir à une
prochaine et je rappelle que cette
soirée électorale elle sera sur toutes
nos plateformes c'est important de le
souligner parce que c'est à plusieurs
endroits des heures différentes 17h55
sur rdi radio canada.ca sur facebook et
youtube ou radio-canada information est
présent ensuite à compter de 19h sur i
see première jean sébastien bernatchez
qui va piloter le tout notre antenne
radio à l'échelle nationale 19h30 sur
ici télé et tou.tv plusieurs rendez vous
pour vous pour suivre cette soirée
électorale qui s'annonce assez
pimenté avec beaucoup de surprises à
prévoir avec aussi beaucoup de suspense
on espère que vous serez là avec nous
pour qu'on puisse vivre cette soirée
ensemble allez je vous ai une prochaine
prenez soin de vous passer une belle fin
de semaine salut
[Musique]